E aí
[Música]
a
268 anos você entende quanto os
significa
a268 anos atrás o Brasil ainda vivia em
uma monarquia naquela época Ainda não
existiam carros muito menos saneamento
básico
268 anos é o tempo equivalente a oito
gerações familiares mais tempo do que o
despendido em 44 guerras mundiais ou 67
eleições presidenciais e mesmo após todo
esse tempo as mulheres ainda são
oprimidas em nossa sociedade e você deve
estar pensando estamos caminhando para
isso as coisas estão melhorando Convido
você a presenciar uma cena em cabo no
Afeganistão em 2015 o alvo dos Homens A
foto é uma mulher ela se chama Roxana
Ela têm entre 19 e 21 anos está sendo
apedrejada até a morte pelo Talibã isso
pode até parecer uma situação medieval e
distante mas hoje o tele banco o país em
que você nasceu mas não é só no distante
Afeganistão que vemos notícias como
essas no Brasil em agosto de 2021 o
corpo da Vanessa Rodrigues foi
encontrado queimado dentro de um saco de
lixo ela estava desaparecida após ser
agredida pelo marido
poderia ter sido eu poderia ter sido
você mulher poderia ter sido sua filha
irmã mãe tia prima avó ou amiga de
qualquer um de nós as mulheres morrem
por serem mulheres em todo o mundo já é
um problema de conhecemos e a cada morte
que anunciada as mesmas perguntas surgem
na minha cabeça como seria se essa
mulher não dependesse financeiramente do
marido eu tivesse condições para buscar
o suporte necessário obviamente Nem
todas as operações deixaram de acontecer
mas algumas histórias teriam desfechos
diferentes estudos apontam que mulheres
economicamente ativas Independentes têm
melhores condições de a agência
doméstica e os abusos por isso o
ambiente de trabalho espaço ideal para
que as mulheres alcancem primeiro a
independência financeira para que então
se sintam fortes o suficiente para lutar
contra outras formas de subjugação mas o
que vemos aqui isso não é possível para
todas as nossas Nem todas as mulheres
conseguem ingressar e crescer no
ambiente corporativo é um problema
estrutural causado por um ambiente que
não foi criado para receber mulheres e
falamos em estatística veremos que a
cada 100 empresas brasileiras 40 possuem
apenas executivos homens e três possuem
uma mulher como se eu
É mas o problema não está somente nas
empresas que já existem mas também na
ausência de incentivos para que mulheres
construam seus próprios negócios já que
dados demonstram que status liderados
por mulheres receberam apenas 2.3 por
cento do financiamento de capital de
risco em 2020
infelizmente estudos da se colegial New
York aponta que para transformar essa
realidade serão necessárias mudanças de
cima das lideranças para baixo mas esse
a gente tira os homens dos lugares de
poder quantas mulheres sobrariam
Atualmente como essas mulheres que
sofrem violência doméstica e
discriminação vão poder mudar sua
situação se nos lugares de
representatividade não tem mulheres que
as entendam que as represente que lute
por elas quem vai garantir que os
interesses e necessidades das mulheres
estão sendo atendidos que as políticas
que vão promover o nosso bem-estar e
crescimento estão sendo pensadas e
alimentadas se mais mulheres não
estiverem usar os cargos de gestão das
instituições públicas e privadas sabemos
que isso não estará sendo feito pelo
menos não de maneira focada e eficaz não
importa o quanto estudemos um nos
preparemos os espaços para crescermos em
nossas carreiras recebemos investimentos
para os nossos negócios e ocupar
posições de comando ainda são muito
poucos nossa existência e nossos sonhos
pessoais e profissionais além dos nossos
direitos estão sendo usurpadas de nós e
o pior não enxergamos isso e fazemos
pouco a respeito pelo menos eu falo por
mim é E durante anos da minha vida eu
não me considerava uma feminista e não
estava tão imersa nas costas do
Movimento Eu não entendi a necessidade
de ter o feminismo como principal pauta
para mim já que não tinha consciência de
que ainda hoje mulheres enfrentam
dificuldades tão absurdas no mercado de
trabalho
somente quando eu me vi vulnerável a
mais uma forma de opressão que minha
percepção sobre o tema mudou foi quando
eu fiquei grávida que eu experimentei o
medo de avisar o meu chefe que eu tinha
perdido o bebê e não poderia fazer uma
viagem internacional marcada porque
tinha feito uma curetagem recente eu fui
trabalhar mesmo assim viajei para fora e
não tive coragem de falar sobre isso na
época
e foi na minha licença-maternidade que
eu tive medo de ser dispensado no dia
que voltasse a trabalhar você que tinha
visto uma matéria demonstrando que cerca
de quarenta e oito por cento das
mulheres são demitidas após a
licença-maternidade foi esse medo que me
despertou eu comecei a buscar mais
informação e educar sobre o que acontece
as mulheres em todos os ambientes da
sociedade isso me fez perceber que essa
luta precisava de mim na verdade ela
precisa de todas as pessoas possíveis e
pelo menos de todas as mulheres
você esposa com ou sem filhos ou
solteira conservadora liberal de
esquerda de direita mais jovem ou mais
madura de todas as religiões e crenças
você mulher que trabalha dentro ou fora
do Lar que já passou por uma situação de
abuso e assédio ou não e já é gestora na
sua organização ou que quer uma dessas
vagas ou não
a lutar pela igualdade econômica e de
direitos é para você mulher feminismo é
para você tome parte nessa luta a favor
das mulheres a questão da mulher na
sociedade precisa de mudanças
estruturais é uma batalha complexa e só
irá ser vencido quando todas as mulheres
entrarem nessa luta Nós não somos
culpados pelas estruturas desiguais mas
infelizmente somos partes muito
relevantes da solução para que ele se
transforme o meu objetivo aqui não é
culpar a mulher nenhuma por ainda não se
reconhecer como feminista mas tentar
despertar em cada uma de vocês a
necessidade de aprofundar mais sobre
esse assunto Infelizmente ser feminista
ainda é visto como algo pejorativo em
muitos contextos são as vistas como
militantes chatas desocupadas quando Na
verdade são as mulheres estão cansadas
de viver em um mundo que não nos protege
não reconhece ou nos legítimas o sismo a
desigualdade econômica e social a
violência em todos os âmbitos da
sociedade tratar da igualdade de gênero
é complexo mas se quiser vamos
alcançá-lo estudiosos já desenharam
passo a passo primeiro precisamos
aceitar que a desigualdade de gênero
existe essa é a única forma de nos
conscientizarmos e lutarmos contra isso
segundo Precisamos falar sobre esse tema
sem ter medo de retaliações apenas
questões apresentadas e amplamente
discutidas são consideradas nos
ambientes de decisão terceiro precisamos
formalizar essa luta através de ONGs e
instituições como a ONU mulheres
comentá-las apoiá-las nos aproximar
delas participar dos eventos e cursos
financiá-las quanto possível sobre esse
ponto você pode começar procurando saber
se na sua cidade alguma instituição de
suporte a Mulheres vítimas de violência
doméstica uma em solo conhecer essas
mulheres suas o e tentar ajudar de
alguma forma é um excelente meio de
aprofundamento com as pautas feministas
e conexão com as mulheres que estão em
maior vulnerabilidade
a e Quarto e último passo precisamos
para o e criar leis e mais do que isso
usar as leis que já temos à nossa
disposição
denunciando os crimes que são cometidos
contra nós aqui eu abro parênteses as
chances de uma mulher denunciar um abuso
ou violência contra si são de sessenta
por cento após o terceiro ato isso
acontece Justamente que mesmos locais
para recebimento dessas denúncias e
aplicação das regiões existentes muitas
vezes não foram projetados para mulheres
ou para nos receber de forma adequada
ainda assim precisamos denunciar no
primeiro sinal de violência ou abuso
contra nossa não esperar pelo terceiro
friso reforço para conquistar a mudanças
tão estruturais com aprovação de leis
seus melhores aplicações até mesmo
aumento de denúncias precisamos
novamente de pessoas exercendo pressão
popular e política não é nada é fácil
não é mesmo é justamente por isso que
precisamos do máximo de apoio possível
é tudo uma das outras
movimento feminista é bastante plural
com pautas distintas as mulheres são
plurais brancas negras indígenas ricas
pobres se gênero transgênero deficientes
casadas e solteiras mães ou não todas
nós sofremos formas diferentes de
opressão mas não há dúvida de que ainda
assim todas nós sofremos eu não sou a
melhor pessoa para falar sobre os
problemas de uma mulher negra e
periférica Mas eu posso ser a melhor
pessoa para estender minha mão para essa
mulher escutar a sua história
facilitaram a oportunidade de emprego
que é um exemplo disso recentemente
anasarca e definir o requisito as mais
de 3.000 empresas do Estado sem sua
principal Bolsa de Valores dos Estados
Unidos ter pelo menos uma mulher e um
diretor diversa e relatar dados sobre a
diversidade do Conselho há pelo menos
uma mulher é muito pouco para ver se a
cinquenta por cento Claro mas daqui
descobriu que mais de 75 por cento de
suas empresas estradas ainda não
atendiam aos requisitos de diversidade
de propostas precisamos começar de algum
lugar e sabem quem é o se Honda na
cidade a de na fila uma mulher que fez
políticas para mulheres é por isso mesmo
que precisamos de mais mulheres no
comando o que não é o caso de só
chegarmos no poder mas quando chegarmos
lá temos que provocar as mudanças
necessárias e nos mantermos alertas como
Simone voar já dizia qualquer crise seja
ela Econômica religiosa ou política
ameaça os direitos das mulheres porque
eles ainda não estão estabelecidos Esse
pro o verdade durante a pandemia quando
mais a metade das mulheres brasileiras
ficaram fora do mercado com 8.5 milhões
de mulheres deixando a força de trabalho
no terceiro trimestre de 2020 o
pensamento de conscientização e denúncia
que atualmente os minhas redes sociais
para compartilhar reflexões cobrar
empresas por melhorias nas suas
políticas de inclusão e denunciar
situações de machismo que eu vejo na
sociedade e se você mulher que como eu
alguns anos atrás ainda não se engajou
no movimento feminista aqui vão algumas
ações simples que você pode começar a
partir de hoje eduque-se sobre o tema
que mesmo feminismo porque esse
movimento foi criado quando o que ele
significa que vem acontecendo as
mulheres dos dias atuais Quais as pautas
levantadas pelas mulheres em contextos
sociais diferentes do seu como isso vem
evoluindo ou não começa a compartilhar o
que você está aprendendo conscientize
todas as pessoas ao seu redor E deixe
que elas saibam a sua posição comece no
jantares com a família na mesa de bar
com os amigos em uma conversa com aquela
sua amiga que votou em candidato de
falas machistas na última eleição
suporte as ideia Só se você vir aqui
algo pode melhorar ofereça ajuda e
quando ela for apresentar o seu projecto
demonstra apoio
música e cobrar dos seus companheiros
uma melhor Divisão das tarefas
domésticas não fique calada quando vi
uma mulher ser menos visada por ser
mulher na empresa em que você trabalha
Você vai vir só o RH alguma liderança
que você tenha mais abertura ainda que
seja em outro setor e se você é uma
liderança feminina por favor não perca a
chance de criar oportunidades para
mulheres reconhecer o valor delas em sua
equipe e cobrar respeito por parte dos
homens que você lhe deram existem também
sugestões que eu coloco em prática e
vejo funcionar
e ao ser convidada para eventos exija
que Metade dos palestrantes mentores
falantes sejam mulher de sugestões de
profissionais
entreviste e contrate mais candidatas
mulheres têm mente ter uma equipe que
seja pelo menos cinquenta por cento
feminina indique mulher Sempre que puder
simplesmente Porque precisamos de mais
mulheres na liderança todos os dias eu
falei minhas redes sociais sobre formas
como nós mulheres podemos ascender
profissionalmente buscar empreender ou
denunciar situações de abuso Essa é a
minha contribuição dentro de um contexto
alinhado com a minha posição atual de
mostrar a importância de engajar mos com
a luta feminista a boa notícia é que
mais do que nunca nós temos
possibilidade de um fazer ser ouvidas
nós temos quase oitenta por cento do
Poder de decisão de compra no Mercado
gerimos famílias inteiras existem
movimentos dedicados a promover o
crescimento das mulheres mas ainda assim
uma ou duas mulheres não vão impedir que
os e Nas condições de roxa no
Afeganistão ou Vanessa no Brasil é
preciso todas nós e não dá para delegar
esse assunto
268 anos não é o período que já
percorremos na história lutando pelo
Direito das mulheres
268 anos é o tempo que vamos levar para
alcançar a igualdade Econômica de gênero
segundo dados do Fórum Mundial econômico
em 2020 em 2015 faltavam 100 anos em
2016 150 anos em 2019 250 ou seja não
estamos evoluindo não dá para esperar
268 anos pela igualdade de gênero Se
quisermos o futuro mais igualitário para
as nossas filhas e netas nós precisamos
começar e nós precisamos começar agora é
E aí